c'estd que nous on souhaite changer de
logique on a une logique de lois qui
sont faites par des médecins pour des
médecins et on est dans une
médicalisation de la mort nous on
souhaite qu'il a une loi qui place tout
simplement la volonté de celle ou celui
qui est en fin de vie au centre des
[Musique]
décisions
Christine Malèvre en juillet 98 cette
infirmière a avoué une trentaine de
meurtres commis sur des patients en fin
de
vie pour la
elle est une meurtrière froide et
cynique pour ses défenseurs Christine
Malèvre est une femme courageuse qui n'a
fait qu'aider à mourir des patients qui
le lui demandai quand on sait que la
médecine n peut plus rien faut-il se
défiler faut-il laisser ses malades
souffrir comment accompagner les malades
vers la
mort doit-on aider ceux qui veulent
mourir il faut que les choses bougent il
faut que les lignes avancent il faut que
la loi soit
réformée les médecins doivent-ils
franchir la frontière de la vie en
administrant la mort c'est pas à eux de
décider je pense que ma vie m'appartient
et j'aimerais bien pouvoir choisir la
façon de la quitter
avecali nous avons décidé de retrouver
les protagonistes de cette affaire et
d'analyser avec eux les conséquences et
les répercussions de ce dossier h
norme le procès en de
malreetteire parler d'ethanasie et puis
d'assassinat elle a d'ailleurs été
condamnée à 10 ans de réclusion pour six
assassinats de patients à l'hôpital de
Mantel
jolie tout commence au centre
hospitalier François Kennet dans les
ivelines ce jour-là Jacques guton un
patient de 71 ans atteint de
pneumopathie meurt brutalement à la
surprise de l'équipe médicale qui
s'interroge l'homme n'était pas mourant
et les médecins lui donnaient encore
plusieurs semaines à
vivre Jacques guton est mort alors
qu'une infirmière Christine Malèvre
était de
service chaque fois qu'elle est dans les
parages des patients meurent
subitement cette fois les aides
soignantes alertent leur chef de
service je mets les choses un peu au
clair en leur demandant est-ce que vous
pensez Christine Malèvre peut avoir eu
un rôle dans le dans le décès du malade
en question euh elle me répond que oui
je précise en leur demandant est-ce que
vous pensez qu'elle a pu le tuer elle me
répondent que
oui des accusations graves qui viennent
briser plusieurs mois de
silence car ce n'est pas la première
fois que les aides soignantes émettent
des doutes après le décès d'un patient
suivi par Christine
Malèvre 15 mois plus tôt en février 97
c'est un homme de 64 ans atteint d'un
cancer des poumons toujours en facee de
traitement actif qui est mort
brutalement il s'appelait Raymond
baudet j'avais vu les médecins moi
personnellement qui m'avait dit que le
traitement allait être très fort mais il
lui donnait au moins 6 mois un an à
vivre son état s'est dégradé en l'espace
de 4
jour il est jamais rentré chez
lui le 6 novembre 97 Hubert Bruel meurt
dans le même hôpital il avait 74 ans lui
aussi souffrait d'un cancer des poumons
et lui non plus ne semblait pas en fin
de
vie mon père était rentré pour une
visite de contrôle pour de ou 3 jours
pour passer des examens et finalement
ben 3 jours il est resté et il est parti
au bout du 3e
jour je me demande pourquoi il est parti
si
vite on n pas pu se dire au revoir
allez on a été pris de cours lui
nous tout le
monde 3 jours plus tard Denise lemaou 48
ans décède dans le même
[Musique]
service le 17 novembre Dominique costman
meurt à l'âge de 47 ans après que
Christine Malèvre lui a administré une
surdose de morphine mais cette fois-ci
il y avait un
témoin je dis enfin Christine qu'est-ce
que tu as fait et là pour la première
fois de ma vie je l'ai vu paniquer elle
m'a dit je me suis trompé la seringue
est partie toute seule ce qui n'était
pas possible parce qu'il faut une sacrée
force pour le
pousser ce jourl marienick Michel a eu
des soupçons bien sûr mais sans preuve
elle s'est tue et les patients ont
continué à
[Musique]
mourir en mars 98 Patrick ogel décède à
l'âge de 53
ans un mois plus tard même sort pour
Patrice Collin 29 ans mais avec la mort
de Jacques guton les collègues de
Christine Malèvre brise le
silence quand j'ai parlé en mai c'est
que je pouvais plus je ne supportais
plus son manque de conscience sa sa
folie 3 jours après avoir été alerté la
direction de l'hôpital transmet
l'affaire à la justice et convoque
l'infirmière je l'ai réussi dans ce
bureau là ici et je lui ai dit je ne
vous suspends pas demain vous irez
travailler aux consultations externes
mais si vous êtes coupable je vous
[Musique]
Christine Malèvre sort de l'hôpital
rentre chez elle et tente de se suicider
elle en réchapine extrémis l'infirmière
est alors placée en hôpital
psychiatrique l'enquête démarre dans le
plus grand secret les collègues et les
supérieurs de l'infirmière défilent au
commissariat il raconte que Christine
Malèvre a toujours eu une attitude
équivoque face à la mort depuis
plusieurs mois
une plaisanterie circul même dans le
service on disait tiens chre est là est
mort les policiers ont rapidement des
éléments concrets pour éer ces bruits de
couloir grâce aux archives de l'hôpital
ils établissent des statistiques elles
sont sans appel pour l'infirmière quand
Christine Malèvre travaille le nombre de
décès grim subitement dans le
service
en juillet 98 placé en garde à vue
Christine Malèvre craque oui elle a tué
une trentaine de
patients l'infirmière est mise en examen
pour homicide
[Musique]
volontaire de mois plus tard l'affaire
fuite dans les médias la presse sen
empart et titre sur
[Musique]
l'euthanasie parle parce que dans dans
l'esprit d'une majorité de gens à
commencé par le mien une infirmière qui
donne la mort ça ne peut être que de
l'ethanasie en aucun cas ça ne peut être
un
meurtre 30 cas
d'euthanasie face à ces révélations
embarrassantes pour l'image de son
hôpital le directeur porte plainte
contre Christine
Malèvre le cas de l'infirmière
interpelle jusqu'à la classe politique
Bernard couchner alors secrétaire d'État
à la santé prend la parole en direct au
20h de France 2 je réagis avec tristesse
avec sérieux mais
avec compassion je pense que c'est un
drame que nous pouvons chacun d'entre
nous affronter l'intervention de Bernard
Kouchner propulse l'euthanasie en Une de
l'actualité durant tout l'été pro et
anti se déchire dans les colonnes des
journaux et sur les plateaux
télé à la rentrée c'est Malèvre
elle-même qui crée l'événement malgré sa
mise en examen elle accepte l'invitation
de l'émission La Marche du siècle dans
quel état d'esprit êtes-vous aujourd'hui
mademoiselle Malèvre et d'abord pourquoi
vous avez décidé de parler ce soir
bonsoir bonsoir bien je crois que
maintenant il faut le débat est ouvert
et en tant qu'infirmière ayant vécu
auprès de malades qui souffraiit qui
réclamit à mourir auprès de famille
aussi mon témoignage peut être u
aujourd'hui tout s fait dans un climat
de confiance avec des avec des patients
avec une toute une relation des
relations humaines se sont instauré
entre ces patients et moi et lorsqu'on a
rien n' proposer au malades pas de
service spécifique quand on on sait que
la médecine n peut plus rien faut-il se
défiler faut-il laisser ces malades
souffrir au lendemain de ce passage dans
la marche du siècle chre Malèvre reçoit
le soutien de l'ADMD l'Association pour
le droit à mourir dans la dignité qui
fait d'elle
l'unicône de fait tout le monde pense
qu'elle était là qu'elle a fait son
travail d'infirmière qu'elle soulageait
qu'il y avait des personnes qui
voulaient mourir que les méchant médecin
ou que la méchante institution
hospitalière ne voulait pas s'en occuper
et elle toute seule dans sa grande
sérénité ou dans sa grande solitude
décidait et soulageit la
personne pour les familles des victimes
la médiatisation de celle qui a ôté la
vie de leurs proches en les privant de
leurs derniers instants est
insupportable elle passe donc à
[Musique]
l'offensive maître Maurice Christine
malère estorté au nu par les partisans
de l'ethanasie par des personnalités
politiques comment le vivent vos clients
il souhaitent savoir ce qu'il y a
réellement dans la procédure dans le
dossier c'est à ce moment-là qu'il
décide de se constituer partie civile de
se regrouper d'avoir accès à la
procédure et c'est alors que c'est une
grande surprise et a un décalage qui est
énorme elle essaie d'expliquer que elle
a eu de nombreuses demande de malades
qui ont sollicité son intervention pour
ABR leur souffrance pour leur donner la
mort on a aucune trace il y a rien il
n'y a que sa seule parole jusqu'à
présent elle était simplement mise en
examen pour meurtre mais là nous
demandons une requalification à savoir
que les actes étaient prémédités il
s'agissait donc
d'assassinat face à ces accusation
l'infirmière change de version
elle qui avait avoué avoir aidé 30
patients à mourir
n'en reconnaî plus que
qu un mois après l'intervention de
Christine Malèvre à la télévision coup
de tonner l'ebdomanaire l'Express publie
un article accablant pour elle un papier
qui s'appuie sur l'enquête statistique
des policiers selon laquelle les
patients meurent beaucoup plus lorsque
Christine Malèvre est en poste le taux
de décès augmente jusqu'à 150
% c'est le choc c'est le choc pour deux
raisons d'abord parce que la journaliste
qui fait cet article s'appelle
Anne-Marie casseret et qui avait eu un
rôle absolument historique dans
l'affaire du sang contaminé bref c'était
une journaliste extrêmement crédible et
de les chiffres et le papier qu'elle
fait est absolument sidéant alors qu'on
restait dans une image de la Sainte
Christine malè de la pauvre infirmière
qui se sacrifiait pour ces tristes
patients là il y a une interrogation
massive massive on s'est dit mais
qu'est-ce qui se passe Christine Malèvre
va réagir elle écrit un livre qui
s'appelle mes aveux qu'est-ce qu'elle
raconte dans ce livre elle a rendu
service à des malades mourants elle a
répondu à je ne sais quel signe de ces
malades qui par déclignement des yeux
lui disait allez il faut que ça s'arrête
il y avait il y a quelque chose de
touchant d'enfantin et en même temps il
y a quelque chose d'un petit peu obscène
quoi alors que l'histoire est encore en
cours que l'affaire n'est pas du tout
jugée on a une jeune femme infirmière
qui raconte qui se plaint il y a quelque
chose d'un petit peu d'un peu
décalé désormais c'est la parole de
Christine Malèvre contre celle des
familles qui refusent d'entendre les
affabulations de
l'infirmière ça m'étonnerait que en
l'espace d'une semaine il lui a demandé
de de mourir ça c'est faux et nous on a
passé toute la semaine avec lui au
contraire il voulait se battre il
l'avait dit je vais me battre et puis je
vais y
arriver malgré les doutes des familles
la justice a du mal à réunir des preuves
tangible la mort de Dominique costman
décédée après une surdose de morphine
retient toutefois l'attention du juge
d'instruction Christine Malèvre avait
décrit une certaine pratique qu'elle
avait tu avec une seringue à morphine
pour laquelle elle aurait fait une
injection massive h et ça c'était on
pouvait le le reconstituer parce qu'elle
avait dit que de telle façon qu'avait
été montée la perfusion il y avait eu
une mauvaise manipulation et que c'est à
cause de cette mauvaise manipulation que
la morphine était partie d'un seul coup
dans le corps du patient et ça ça a été
reconstitué dans mon
bureau une reconstitution qui porte un
sérieux coup à la version de Christine
malèvres malgré les différentes
tentatives dans le bureau du juge
d'instruction il s'avère impossible
d'injecter par accident autant de
morphine d'un coup c'est le seul élément
matériel tangible à mon sens
incontestable à partir du moment où sur
ce point j'estime qu'il y a une
contevérité alors le reste de ces
déclarations peuvent être entachés du
saut de la
contevérité en juin 99 le parquet de
versaill recalifie les faits Christine
Malèvre est désormais mise en examen
pour
assassinat pour le juge l'infirmière n'a
pas aidé à mourir elle a voulu
tuer Christine malè encourt désormais la
réclusion criminel à
perpétuité maître Maurice
cettequalification c'est une vioire pour
vos clients c'est simplement une
adaptation à la réalité du dossier ce
pourquoi on était dans une forme
d'étonnement c'est que il a fallu que
nous prenions l'initiative de solliciter
cette requalification vous allez à ce
moment-là employer une phrase qui va
marquer les esprits vous qualifiez
Christine Malèvre de tueuse en série ça
n'est pas du tout cette femme qui a agi
avec compassion pour soulager la
souffrance des malades c'est une femme
qui en réalité est en souffrance
personnelle importante et qui n'a pas su
du
tout
transposer je dirais une relation qui
soit une relation saine avec ses malades
c'est une relation perverse Christine
Malèvre ressemble davantage à une tueuse
en série qu'à la Madonne de
l'euthanasie
[Musique]
le sérial killer moi ça me donnait
l'impression qu'on parlait de quelqu'un
d'autre ça ne peut pas être Christine
toutes les personnes qui connaissent
Christine ont été mais profondément
choqué par ces titres là c'est de la
révolte c'est de la colère c'est de
l'humiliation après 18 mois
l'instruction est bouclée Christine
Malèvre devra répondre de cet assassinat
devant la Cour
d'Assise l'infirmière change alors
d'avocat mais aussi de stratégie elle ni
tout en blocè rien il n'y a pas de lien
de causalité entre son geste et le décès
des patients qui vous le savez étaent
quasiment tous en fin de vie et dans des
condition
atroce le procès de Christine Malèvre
s'ouvre devant la Cour d'assise de
Versailles l'infirmière qui risque la
prison à vie arrive libre au côté de son
avocat les parties civiles se succèdent
et elle le martellent encore et encore
jamais leurs proches n'ont demander à
mourir seul le témoignage de Pascal
Collin le frère de la plus jeune des
victimes n'accable pas
l'accusé quand vous voyez votre frère de
29 ans sur son lit qui pèse 45 kg dans
un état pitoyable même si elle n'a pas
demandé la vie de la famille ni des
médecins je ne pourrais moi à titre
personnel son frère je ne pourrais pas
lui en
vouloir pourtant l'avocat général
réclame au moins 10 ans d'emprisonnement
pour celle qu'il qualifie de voleuse de
temps de voleuse
d'amour maître Libman l'avocat de
Christine Malèvre tente lui de minimiser
les fait reprochés à sa
cliente lorsque j'ai plaidé j'ai demandé
pour les cas qui n'étaient pas à mon
sens établis bien entendu de la quitter
et pour les deux cas qu'elle avait
reconnu de dire qu'elle n'était pas
coupable de ça ne veut pas dire qu'elle
n'est pas à l'origine de elle n'est pas
coupable
de après 4 heur de délibérer Christine
Malèvre est acquittée dans le dossier de
Denise lemou mais elle est reconnu
coupable des six autres assassinats qui
lui étaient reprochés
elle est condamnée à 10 ans de prison et
à l'interdiction d'exercer la profession
d'infirmière à
vie Christine Malèvre n'est pas reconnue
coupable de la mort de Denise l Maout
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé dans ce cas
précis alors nous ne savons pas parce
que les décisions ne sont pas motivées à
l'époque on peut imaginer justement des
discordances en termees d'emploi du
temps c'est-à-dire que l'absence de
Christine Malèvre à certains moment où
Madame Le Maout a
été suivi a pu jeter un doute dans
l'esprit des jurés et a conduit à cet
acquitement mais ça n'est qu'une qu'une
hypothèse si condamnation et un
acquitement selon vous les jurés ont
pris en compte cette notion d'euthanasie
ou pas du tout alors moi je crois pas du
tout je pense qu'en réalité les jurés
ont très très vite compris qu'on nétait
pas en présence du tout d'une affaire
qui pouvait conduire à un débat de
société sur
[Musique]
l'euthanasie ça a été de la colère de
sentiment de d'injustice
d'incompréhension
de de dégoût face à un système qui avait
pas compris qui n'a pas compris ou qui
n'a pas voulu
comprendre dans tous les hôpitaux de
France les pratiques d'aideent à mourir
F qutidiennement et apparemment il y a
qu'à l'hôpital de tout ça ne se fait
pas chrisinee Malèvre fait immédiatement
appel de sa
condamnation Christine Malèvre observera
de sa
prison le débat national qui s'est
amplifié du fait de son
sacrifice observera de sa prison le
débat national sur les soins palliatifs
et
l'euthanasie
[Musique]
quelques mois seulement après cette
condamnation un nouveau cas d'euthanasie
va bouleverser la France une affaire qui
dépasse largement l'intimité d'une
chambre
[Musique]
d'hôpital en septembre 2000 vincentbert
un de 19 ans est victime d'un grave
accident de la route hospitalisé au
centreliau marin de Berk surmer il se
réveille après 6 mois de coma aveugle
muet et
têtraplégique Vincent ne peut
communiquer avec ses proches qu'avec son
pouce droit mais il est parfaitement
[Musique]
conscient vincentbert le sait la
médecine ne peut plus rien pour
lui le 30 novembre 2002 il adresse une
lettre bouleversante au président de la
République Monsieur Chirac je m'appelle
Vincent Humbert j'ai 21 ans j'ai eu un
accident de la circulation tous mes sens
vitaux ont été touchés vous avez le
droit de grâce et moi je vous demande le
droit de mourir je voudrais que vous
sachiez que vous êtes ma dernière
[Musique]
chance maisqu refuse d'accéder à cette
demande il ne peut pas accorder le droit
de
mourir ce refus n'entame en rien la
détermination de Vincent Humbert dont le
combat est porté par sa mère
Marie il a plus d'un an qu' me parle de
de la mort je me rappelle un soir je
suis dit ben comme tous les soirs
bonsoir mon titi à demain je
t'aime il m'a repris la main en me
disant mais arrête maman tu m'aimes pas
si tu m'aimer tu me laisserais
[Musique]
mourir maître Vigier Marie Humbert vous
raconte qu'est-ce qu'elle vous dit de la
souffrance de son fils Vincent la nuit
il est seul Marie elle est partie elle
peut plus être à l'hôpital Vincent la
nuit il a il a des douleurs dans des
dans des membres qui sont morts quand sa
mère vient elle comprend tout de suite
elle va changer de position quand dans
la nuit une infirmière vient elle allume
la lumière elle regarde il y a pas de
difficulté il respire elle éteint la
lumière elle repart et il va rester
toute la nuit avec ses douleurs c'est
insupportable et et et quand il dit je
ne veux plus je ne peux plus c'est c'est
au-delà de mes forces je veux mourir ce
cri mari entend sans cesse c'est c'est
c'est épouvantable pour elle ce gamin
qu'elle porte à bout de bras mais
qu'elle aime tellement fort ce retour en
arrière il est il est de nouveau dans
son ventre il est et il faut qu'elle
l'aide à
mourir le 24 septembre 2003 face aux
appels désespérés de son fils Marie
Himbert passe à l'acte elle injecte
d'importantes doses de barbiturique à
Vincent qui tombe alors dans un profond
Comat il est admis en urgence dans le
service de réanimation du docteur
Frédéric
chaoir marieber est placé en garde à
vue maître Vigier lorsque la procédure
est lancé quelle est la réaction de
mariebert d'abord ce n'est pas une
réaction de surprise parce que elle le
sait elle le sait déjà depuis un moment
elle est évidemment totalement déterminé
elle ne pense qu'à une chose le sort de
Vincent et je dois dire que le sort
judiciaire à ce moment-là lui est
totalement indifférent concrètement
qu'est-ce qui lui a reproché elle a
empoisonné tenté d'empoisonner son fils
et donc on lui reproche une tentative
d'homicide ou une tentative d'assassinat
c'est-à-dire vouloir donner la mort à
son fils c'est vrai elle le revendique
et l'avoir prémédité le revendique aussi
et puis les choses vont un peu se
précipiter puisque en fait Vincent est
hors de danger en réalité on va le
comprendre très vite donc c'est
absolument dramatique pour Marie qui
d'ailleurs est hospitalisée pour des
raisons psychiques parce que elle parce
que c'est insoutenable pour elle parce
que parce qu'elle craque parce que elle
se dit que Vincent et bien va survivre
et va être dans un état encore pire que
celui dans lequel il était en somme elle
n'aura pas réussi
donc c'est dramatique et de jours plus
tard le docteur Chao administre à
Vincent du chlorure de potassium pour
l'aider à partir confronté à la famille
à la souffrance de la famille à la
demande de la famille à ce que vient de
faire une mère je crois que là il il va
considérer qu'il ne peut pas faire
autrement qu'il faut qu'il le fasse et
il va accepter ce choix qui a été celui
de Vincent d'abord celui de Marie mais
celui de Marie c'est celui de Vincent
celui de toute la famille et et donc là
Vincent s
[Musique]
Meur Vincent Himbert est inhumé le 1er
octobre 2003 à Berk
surmer en présence de ses proches et de
l'équipe médicale qui l'a
[Musique]
soigné hasard du calendrier le lendemain
la cour d'appel de Paris se penche à
nouveau sur le cas de Christine Malèvre
à l'occasion de ce procès en appel le
débat sur l'euthanasie est dans toutes
les têtes he puisqu'il vient d'avoir
l'affaire Vincent Humbert vous craignez
que ça détourne l'attention des jurés du
tout du tout parce que notre travail
sera justement de montrer que cette
instrumentalisation qui est faite euh
ben nous ne sommes pas dans la situation
de Monsieur Humbert nous sommes en
présent d'une femme qui a qui a dérapé
et qui n'a pas su établir une relation
équilibrée avec ses malades et qui
déontologiquement a violé toutes les
règles et pénalement
également crispé et inquiète les sœurs
de l'accusé se sont installé au fond de
la salle
d'audience c'était toujours le même
discours mais bon qui qui peut se
justifier c'est-à-dire voilà des
patientes qui voulaient mourir qui
souffrai trop et la défense se metttait
sur cette cette autoroute là de
l'émotion de l'empathie de la compassion
alors que plus les jours et les
audiences du procès se passaient plus on
avait le sentiment que les choses
étaient un peu différentes que que
Christine malè était trop présente on
avait plus de doute on avait non on
avait guerre de doute Christine Malèvre
va s'adresser à la salle vous vous
souvenez de ce qu'elle dit on a le
sentiment qu'elle qu'elle ne comprend
pas l'histoire ou qu'elle est toujours
dans la même histoire qu'elle est
toujours embourbée par elle-même
l'important d'une certaine façon c'est
ni le médecin ni l'infirmière c'est la
personne malade mais non là elle parle
d'elle le 15 octobre 2003 la Cour
d'appel de Paris rend son
verdict l'infirmière est reconnu
coupable de 6 des se assassinats qui lui
sont reprochés elle est acquitté pour le
cas de Denise l Maou comme en première
instance la condamnation de Christine
Malèvre est donc maintenue cette fois
avec 12 ans de prison et toujours
interdiction d'exercer la profession
d'infirmière à
vie
Olivier Maurice 2 ans de plus qu'en
première instance c'est une victoire
pour vous c'est pas une victoire c'est
la réponse
judiciaire à un dossier important parce
que il était présenté comme quelque
chose qui allait éventuellement pouvoir
émouvoir l'opinion publique et susciter
un débat au Parlement et c'est un échec
pour ceux qui ont tenté
d'instrumentaliser Christine
[Musique]
Malèvre quelques jours après la
condamnation de Christine Malèvre et
moins d'un mois après la mort de Vincent
Humbert le procureur de Boulogne surmer
ouvre une information judiciaire contre
le docteur
chaois le médecin est poursuivi pour
empoisonnement avec préméditation il
risque la prison à
perpétuité Marie Himbert elle est
poursuivie pour administration de
substances toxiques commise avec
préméditation sur personne vulnérable
elle encours 5 ans de prison maître
Vigier même mise en cause la maman de
Vincent va continuer à se battre son
combat c'est le droit de mourir
dignement et le droit du suicide
assister en quelque sorte problème de
Vincent c'est je veux mourir je n'en ai
pas les moyens je peux pas me donner la
mort Vincent avec des facultés un peu
moins réduites il se donne la mort tout
seul là Vincent ne peut pas il n'a aucun
moyen de se donner la mort et il veut
mourir il faut que les choses bougent il
faut que les lig avance il faut que la
loi soit réformée il faut qu'il y ait
une loi Vincent Humbert il faut que ça a
servi à quelque chose ça a servi parce
que Vincent n'est plus là que c'est un
soulagement immense et il faut que ça
serve à d'autres et en janvier 2005
maître Marie Humbert est mise en examen
comment est-ce qu'elle vit cette
décision elle ne la vit pas mal parce
qu'elle la limite je crois qu'elle la
souhaite il faut être clair à ce
moment-là ce qui est envisager c'est que
cette procédure judiciaire ce sera une
tribune ce sera une tribune qui
deviendra une tribune politique la cour
d'assis sera une tribune politique le
procès ce sera un débat comme il y en a
eu quelques 30 ans avant sur
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
le docteur chaois lui aussi va être mis
en examen comment est-ce qu'il réagit
c'est un homme qui semble être un
notable de
province père de famille avec et du jour
au lendemain ce geste qu'il fait aussi
par soutien pour Vincent et pour Marie
bouleverse sa vie il sait que s'il est
renvoyé il peut être condamné il mesure
lui cette aléa et il sait que sa vie
professionnel son amour de ce métier
tout peut être
rompu en février 2006 2 ans et demi
après la mort de Vincent Himbert la juge
d'instruction délivre un non lieu il n'y
aura donc pas de procès ni pour le
docteur chaois ni pour la mer de
Vincent lorsque cette décision est
rendue votre cliente a une réaction
assez
inattendue ce que la juridiction de
Boulogne turmer va choisir c'est de
considérer que à la fois docteur chosois
et Marie Himbert était sous une
contrainte morale résultant pour Marie
de la demande presscente de son fils
comme si Vincent avait exercé une
pression telle sur sa mère qu'elle
n'aurait pas pu y résister et donc c'est
d'une violence inouie pour elle parce
que ce choix qu'elle revendique et bien
on lui enlève ce choix on lui dit qu'on
ne on ne respecte plus son libre arbitre
c'est pas vous qui avez décidé ça vous y
avez été contrainte une contrainte
d'ailleurs irrésistible la preuve c'est
qu'elle vous exonère de responsabilité
c'est insupportable le choix qu'elle
fait est un choix d'amour c'est un choix
philosophique et c'est aussi un choix
fondamentalement politique et on le lui
enlève c'est dramatique et le docteur
chaois comment accueille-t-il ce nonlieu
alors pour lui par contre c'est un
soulagement il faut imaginer que s'il
est renvoyé devant une cour d'assise et
condamné en tant que médecin pour avoir
donné la mort volontairement à quelqu'un
donc pour un
homicide c'est c'est le contraire du
serment d'Hippocrate dans une certaine
mesure on aurait pu lui faire
interdiction d'exercer contrôle
judiciaire on aurait pu dire écoutez
docteur vous n'exercez plus la médecine
ce double nonlieu est bien sûr une
victoire pour les partisans de
l'euthanasie mais aussi un moyen
d'interpeller la classe politique très
réticente à s'emparer de la question de
la fin de
[Musique]
vie Jean-Luc Romer pas de procès ni
contre la mère de Vincent Himbert ni
contre le médecin qu'est-ce qui a euh
motivé cette décision pour vous c'est la
justice qui est compatissante et c'est
elle qui fait que ces personnes se
retrouvent pas se retrouvent pas en
prison euh et ça c'est euh c'est pas
normal c'est pas normal parce que ça
veut dire que les députés les sénateurs
ne jouent pas leur rôle ne font pas leur
travail la justice fait ce que le
législateur ne ne fait
[Musique]
pas
face au retentissement de l'affaire
Humbert le 22 avril 2005 le Parlement
adopte enfin une loi sur la fin de vie
la loi Leonetti à peine voté le texte
suscite de nombreuses
critiques Jean-Luc Romer cette loi
Leonetti elle propose des avancées
est-ce que pour vous c'est suffisant
elle propose des avancées oui et non
globalement pour la personne qui meurt
elle est toujours pas au centre de la
décision puisque c'est toujours ceux qui
sont autour du lit qui décident
évidemment pour les médecin c'était
c'était c'était important parce que elle
le protège d'une certaine manière cette
loi notamment elle permet à un médecin
de faire ce qu'on appelle le double
effet c'est-à-dire que un médecin pour
soulager vos vos douleurs il vous
injecte un produit par exemple de la
morphine et puis sachant que s'il
augmente la dose de morphine vous allez
mourir en fait il ne sera pas poursuivi
parce que sa première intention c'est de
soulager votre douleur donc vous voyez
c'est une grande sécurité pour eux une
grande hypocrisie aussi quelque part
après on a proclamé un certain nombre de
choses la fin de l'acharnement thérap
petique qu'on a rebaptisé obstination
des raisonnables on a créé les
directives anticipées la possibilité
pour chacune et chacun d'entre nous
d'écrire ses volontés au cas où on ne
serait plus en capacité de le dire sauf
que voilà on voit bien dans la réalité
tout ça est quand même toujours autour
d'une mort médicalisée pour vous il
faudra aller beaucoup plus loin bah
c'estàd que nous on souhaite changer de
logique on a une logique de lois qui
sont faites par des médecins pour des
médecins et on est dans une
médicalisation de la mort nous on
souhaite qu' une loi qui place tout
simplement la volonté de celle ou celui
qui est en fin de vie au centre des
décisions les soutiens de Vincent
Himbert eux attendent encore plus de la
loi
Leonetti pourtant adopté après l'émotion
suscitée par la mort du jeune homme elle
ne s'applique pas au cas comme le
sien ce sont des lois sur la fin de vie
pour des patients dans des situations
incurables mais avec un pronostic vital
engagé pronostic vital de Vincent n'a
jamais été engagé aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui on est dans la même
situation un gamin comme Vincent Herbert
victime du même accident qui a une
vingtaine d'années mais il vit et on a
pas de vraie solution c'est dire que il
va mourir comment va mourir dans des
souffrances atroces il faut que ce soit
transparent que la volonté puisse être
exprimée et qu'elle puisse être
respectée dans des cas comme ce de
Vincent aberbert et aujourd'hui on n
toujours pas réglé cette
[Musique]
situation pour les patients comme pour
le corps médical la la loi Leonetti de
2005 est donc loin de répondre à toutes
les questions en 2011 13 ans après le
cas Christine Malèvre une autre affaire
fait les gros titres le docteur Nicolas
bonnemison un médecin urgentiste est
accusé d'avoir accéléré la mort de SEP
patients le docteur bonne maison
intervenait dans ce qu'on appelle le
temps de l'agonie c'est-à-dire que il
faisait un geste médical qui au mieux ou
au pire raccourcissait une vie de 1h 2h
on était dans l'extrême
agonie des patients à l'agonie que le
docteur bonne maison aurait aidé à
mourir en leur injectant du curard un
médicament non
homologué cette décision l'urgentiste
l'aurait prise seul sans en discuter
avec ses collègues ce qui est contraire
à la
loi le docteur bonne maison en cours la
réclusion criminelle à
perpétuité il bénéficie pourtant d'un
soutien sans faille y compris de la part
des proches de ses victimes
il l'a fait parce qu'il a voulu nous
aider c'est c'est pas c'est pas un crime
de d'aider les gens à à mourir dignement
c'est pas un crime le crime c'est de les
laisser mourir comme
[Musique]
ça
maître Arnaud Dupin le docteur bonne
maison a-t-il été soutenu durant son
procès la majeure partie des gens qui
ont été confrontés à la mort et qui ont
été accompagnés par le docteur bonne
maison l'ont soutenu parce que il leura
tellement apporté d'humanité dans ces
moments difficiles qu'ils ne l'ont
jamais vu comme l'auteur d'un crime ses
collègues aussi vont le soutenir
publiquement oui parce que les médecins
sont confrontés quotidiennement à cela
la grande hypocrisie en France c'est de
ne jamais parler de la mort ne jamais
parler de la fin de vie on s'imagine que
tamourbattant on va faire de nouvelles
lois pour modifier les choses mais
pourtant cette loi elle existait alors
qu'on lui reproche de ne pas avoir
marqué sur le dossier comme il aurait dû
le faire mais c'est une infraction à la
loi c'est pas un crime malgré ses
soutiens et alors que l'instruction est
toujours en cours le docteur bonne
maison est radié par le Conseil national
de l'Ordre comment vit-il cette sanction
administrative c'est terrible parce que
ce qui car sa vie c'est la médecine donc
sans médecine il y a pas de vie il vit
ça comme un immense déchirement parce
qu'il pensait que ses pères allaient
pouvoir le comprendre et que ses
témoignages et ses soutiens qui venaent
de professeur de médecins éminents allit
justement permettre à l'institution de
comprendre ce qu'il lui était réellement
arrivé en juin 2014 le procès du docteur
bonne maison débute devant la Cour
d'assise de PT les soutiens de
l'urgentiste sont là en nombre une seule
famille s'est constituée parti civile à
la barre pas moins de 70 témoins
défilent tout le gratin médical est là
pour soutenir le docteur bonne
[Musique]
maison
Bernard couchner vous avez été témoin au
procès du docteur bonne maison pourquoi
mais parce qu'on m'a demandé parce que
j'estimais d'être un tout petit peu
qualifié pour témoigner que dans
l'imperfection absolue des lois
françaises il avait fait ce qu'il avait
pu on a l'impression que c'est un
assassinat à chaque fois quand on parle
de ça c'est pas un assassinat c'est la
volonté des gens dont les médecins ont
la charge maître Dupain que plaidez-vous
nous plaidons l'acquitement on le plaide
à la fois sur un côté humain mais aussi
sur un côté technique c'était un peu
fastidieux mais c'était indispensable
parce qu'il y avait se cas dont on
devait répondre et il a fallu les
prendre minutieusement un par un à
expliquer pourquoi il n'y avait pas de
crime et que le médecin n'avait pas
commis le crime d'empoisonnement qui lui
était reproché et verdict c'est
l'acquittement l'acquitement avec une
motivation très claire le docteur bonne
maison n'a jamais eu l'intention de
donner la mort quel que soit les
médicaments et les substances qu'il ait
pu
[Applaudissements]
utiliser accueilli par des
applaudissements accueilli par un
soulagement nous sortons de la cour
d'assise pour nous Fri un chemin il
fallait que les les les les policiers
nous nous encerclent parce qu'il y avait
une espèce
de joie collective parce que c'était
fini comment il réagit lui à ce verdict
il est ému parce
que il est entendu il est ému parce que
il se sent médecin à ce
momentl le parquet fait immédiatement
appel de cet acquitement et le Conseil
d'État confirme la radiation du docteur
bonne maison de l'ordre des
médecins exurgentiste réintègre
finalement l'hôpital de Bayonne mais
dans un service
[Musique]
administratif près d'un an et demi après
son acquitement Nicolas bonnmaon est de
retour dans le box des
accusés maître Dupin le procès en appel
a lieu à anger les soutiens du docteur
bonne maison sont toujours là toujours
encore et et toujours ce sont des
Français qui ne comprennent pas cet ach
ement derrière tout cela cet acharnement
sur le docteur bonne maison et qui
attend beaucoup encore une fois de la
justice de leur pays comment le docteur
bonne maison vit-il cette nouvelle
épreuve il le
vit difficilement en ayant quand même
l'idée que sa
victoire il ne pourra pas la rééditer
parce qu'il s'en poindre que les armes
sont beaucoup plus affutées et il faut
arracher coûte que coûte sa condamnation
donc c'est un procès extrêmement tendu
il pense que c'est peut-être une
décision autre que judiciaire qui se
joue que c'est une décision politique
que c'est une décision sociétale
nousappréhendons tous nous avons tous
cette image en tête mais nous faisons
tout pour nous battre jusqu'au bout il
ne pouvait pas y avoir autre chose qu'un
acquitement il ne pouvait pas y avoir
autre chose que de dire que le docteur
bonne maison n'a jamais empoisonné
personne il n'a jamais commis de CRIM
d'empoisonnement voilà ce que nous
étions venus dire le docteur bonne
maison sort de l'audience entourée de
son épouse et de ses avocats tout
sourire soulager dit-il applaudit par
ses soutiens il vient pourtant d'être
condamné à 2 ans de prison avec surcis
coupable d'avoir attenté à la vie d'une
seule de ses patiente à quitté pour les
six autres au bénéfice du
doute quand on lit bien finalement on a
l'impression que derrière cette décision
de justice qui pour moi est un
acquitement il y a juste un mot pour
l'opinion publique c'est pas rien c'est
un tout petit peu c'est une décision
comme je le dis pour montrer que on n'a
pas donné une absolution totale une
semaine après la fin de son procès il va
se passer quelque chose de grave oui il
tente de se
suicider il tente de mettre fin à séjour
il est retrouvé dans dans un bois par
par un joger
et ironie du sort le médecin qui reçoit
l'appel au SAMU de Bayonne comprend ce
qui se passe comprend que c'est un de
ses collègues et va mettre en œuvre un
dispositif qui va justement lui
permettre d'être très rapidement soigné
qu'est-ce qui selon vous l'a poussé à
commettre ce geste extrême un trop plein
peut-être un trop plein de tout et très
certainement l'absence
[Musique]
d'espoir qu'est-ce que vous retenez
Bernard Kouchner de cette affaire bonne
maison la
solitude la solitude des des médecins
qui ont
choisi
d'accomplir ce qu'il pensait être ou
était
sûr que c'était le désir du malade le
désir de de l'homme ou de la femme qui
était
[Musique]
là en février 2016 les parlementaires
revoient leur copies ils adoptent une
nouvelle loi sur la fin de vie la deè en
ans on a bien senti que la première loi
était une loi faite pour les médecins
pour rassurer les médecins leur donner
un canne la deuxème loi le curseur va se
dévelop déplacer un petit peu vers les
patients et pour cela deux éléments un
peu nouveaux ce qu'on appelle les
directives anticipées avant ces
directives anticipées n'étaient pas ce
qu'on appelle opposarme c'estdire que le
médecin pouvait en prendre connaissance
et après il faisait ce qu'il veut là le
médecin est obligé de suivre les
directive anticipée ça c'est un premier
changement et le deuxième changement qui
était le plus le plus problématique
était autour de ce qu'on appelle la
sédation terminale c'est-à-dire la
possibilité pour dire les choses
rapidement lorsque des patients sont en
fin de vie dans des situation de de
maladie incurable et qu'il le souhaite
la possibilité de les endormir jusqu'au
décès ce nouvel arsenal législatif
va-t-il permettre d'éviter de nouvelles
affaires pour moi c'est une grosse
opération de communication c'est-à-dire
qu'on reprend ce qu'il y a dans la loi
de 2005 on y rajoute les décrets 2010 et
cetera et on nous dit il y a deux
nouveaux droits dans cette loi le droit
de de de dormir avant de mourir bon qui
est en fait une sédation terminale on
vous endort vous allez plus jamais vous
réveiller mais c'est pas un droit dans
la réalité des choses puis c'est encore
sous le contrôle des médecins on est
toujours dans une affaire médicale et la
deuxième chose c'est les directives
anticipées dont on nous a dit qu'elles
étaient désormais opposables c'estàdire
ce que vous avez écrit quand vous étiez
conscient euh et bien ça doit s'imposer
au médecin dans la réalité des choses
c'est comme dans les contrats vous savez
il y a des trucs écrit en gros puis en
bas il y a des exceptions et là il y a
deux exceptions qui enlèvent les choses
puisque les directives anticipées elles
ne sont pas opposables s'il y a urgence
vitale ce qui arrive quand même un peu
souvent c'est 50 % des certificates de
décès sont faits aux urgences des
hôpitaux et puis la deuxième exception
c'est que si le médecin estime que vos
directives sont manifestement
inappropriées notion juridique que
personne ne connaît qui qui a été
inventé par Monsieur Leonetti et dont
d'ailleurs plusieurs magistrats de la
Cour de cassation ont dit que un jour il
y aura forcément des problèmes avec ça
parce qu'il y aura des médecins qui ne
voudront pas les respecter juste par
rapport à à leur leur leur éthique leur
religion voilà est-ce qu'on peut faire
quelque chose pour combler les failles
de cette loi ou est-ce qu'il faut
imaginer toute autre chose moi jeil faut
partir d'une autre logique alors
évidemment les devoirs du médecin et
puis les protections qu'on a mis dans le
cadre des autres lois bien sûr qu'il
faut garder ça mais je vous dis
maintenant il faut une logique qui mette
le mort au centre de la décision celui
qui est en fin de vie et cette loi elle
est attendu et c'est pas nous qui le
disons même la croix a eu l'audace de
publier un sondage qui nous dit que 89 %
des Français voudrai des lois qui
permettent la légalisation de
l'euthanasie du ou du suicide assisté ou
les deux donc je pense qu'il a un moment
ça fait 20 ans qu'on a les mêmes
sondages il serait temps que les
politiques entendent
parallèlement à l'adoption de cette loi
une nouvelle structure est mise en place
en 2016 par le
gouvernement le Centre national des
soins palliatifs et de la fin de
vie Véronique Fournier vous êtes
présidente du Centre national des soins
palliatifs quelle est la mission de ce
centre elle est triple elle est
premièrement d'informer les nos
concitoyens de leurs droits en matière
de fin de vie la deuxième mission du
centre c'est de collecter l'ensemble des
données disponibles sur la fin de vie et
sur les soins palliatifs et la troisième
mission du centre c'est de participer à
l'évaluation des politiques publiques en
matière de soins palliatifs et de fin de
vie est-ce que les Français sont tous
égaux face à l'accès au soins palliatifs
alors nous on a fait des cartographies
qui montrent que en fonction des
départements et des régions il y a pas
la même densité en soin palliatif de
manière pragmatique ça coûte très cher
je pense pas qu'on puisse dire que ça
coûte très cher par contre ce qu'on peut
dire c'est que ça rapporte pas beaucoup
d'argent aujourd'hui les hôpitaux il
fonctionnent grâce au budget qu'on leur
alloue et le budget il est proportionnel
à la technologie qu'il déploie or les
soins palliatifs ce sont des soins non
technologiques donc il y a peu d'argent
qui viennent avec ces soins-là comme ça
ne rapporte pas beaucoup d'argent ce
n'est pas valorisé dans les hôpitaux
pourquoi en France est qu'on oppose les
soins palliatifs à l'euthanésie ou au
suicide
pour des raisons historiques et
culturelles c'est en 1984 qu'on a
commencé à développer les soins
palliatifs précisément pour résister à
la tentation euthanasique et donc il
existe dans le monde des soins
palliatifs un sentiment de nécessité de
résistance très forte je peux tout à
fait comprendre qu'on résiste à cette
tentation ou à cette façon de vouloir
mourir c'est un peu dommage que les deux
ne puissent pas coexister
aujourd'hui de plus en plus de pays dans
le monde autorisent l'euthanasie à nos
frontières la Belgique le Luxembourg et
les Pays-Bas ont légalisé le suicide
assisté c'est donc vers ces pays que se
tourn celles et ceux qui veulent choisir
leur fin de
vie on a la même époque que celle de
l'avortement où les femmes qui avaient
les moyens all se faire avorter à
l'étranger les autres et bien elles
avaient les feuseus d'ange certaines on
mourit et ben nous on est dans la même
situation on a les gens qui partent à
l'étranger parce qu'ils ont les moyens
ou les relations euh et puis les autres
et ben ils suicident violemment il faut
avoir de l'argent pour partir doucement
selon son ton bon vouloir c'est pas
c'est pas juste la vie n'appartient ni
au médecin ni si je peux me permettre
avec beaucoup de précaution au bon Dieu
mais appartient à l'individu
et luimême peut décider doit décider
doit pouvoir décider de la façon dont il
quitte cette
[Musique]
vie en France l'affaire Christine
Malèvre libre depuis août 2007 et celle
de Vincent Himbert ont su libérer la
parole et faire évoluer la justice sur
la question de la fin de
vie pourtant l'euthanasie reste toujours
un délire